yeah thanks and hello everybody I am
Catherine I am head of Consulting at I
wonder and I'm here today with my
colleague and data scientist yuchong and
we want to talk with you about chatbots
today now chat Bots have received a lot
of attention lately to due to the
release of chat GPT but also besides
that Innovation there exists a variety
of chat Bots ranging from simple Chit
Chat to more sophisticated use cases
like the diagnosis of technical or
medical problems in our case we wanted
to build a chatbot
for the retrieval of data as an add-on
to an existing web app informing about
the e-mobility infrastructure in Germany
so besides just showing the kpis we
regard as interesting to the user we
wanted to give them the possibility to
extract exactly the data interesting for
them hence ichung built a chatbot based
on the rasa framework and she will
explain now in more detail how she did
this
yes thank you so
before I really dive into the
implementation details I want to first
talk about the big concept behind
chatbot on and that is an Erp
so we know that chatbot is just one
application of NLP and there are also
many more other NLP tasks such as
sentiment analysis where we detect the
sentiment from a text or we classify the
text based on into the topics and we
also use translators every day to
understand other languages as well as
Auto completion when we try to type
words more quickly
and yeah
so um but behind all these tasks there's
something in common that is the machines
needs to understand the
information and content in the Raw data
which whether it is text assigned or
image
they need to all be converted into
numeric representations
and so this is the most important
concept I will say in NLP and I will
come back to it shortly again
so now say we have for such a sentence
electric costs are the futures the first
step we usually do is to get the tokens
out of it and there are many different
ways to do it the most simple way is
that we use white space as delimiter and
in the end we will get the tokens as
individual words or characters and a
token is not necessary a word but it can
also be a
support
and as long as we have the tokens we can
now think about again how we want to
represent them and again they are also
different ways to do it let's start with
something more simple like on the sparse
representations so
the typical sparse representations
include one hot encoding where we
generate a vector which has the same
length as the length of the vocabulary
in the text and at the index where this
word is located in the vocabulary we
will have a one all the other elements
are zeros
and if we now want to generate directly
our representation for the whole
sentence we can use the bag of words
which basically count the frequency of
the words in the text
now we see that although this past
presentations are easy to understand and
Implement they have obvious drawbacks
first we have a lot of zeros in our
representations which means we need a
lot of memory to store this kind of
usefulness information and this kind of
representation is typical typically not
so reaching the information it contains
it captures the synthetic information
but not the semantic therefore we have
to use the dance representations
and
let's first have a look at the static
embeddings one of the most commonly used
technique is what to vac and it can be
achieved by using two different
algorithms first is simple and the
second is Skip Grant and I want to hear
quickly explain how skip gram works
so we have again this sentence and the
core idea of it is we want to predict
the context word given a input word so
let's say we have a window size of one
we Slide the window from left to right
and
so for the first input word electric
which is marked in yellow we consider
one word before it and one word after it
in this word we generate the training
pairs
and after we get all these training
pairs we can change our Channel neural
network and to calculate the errors and
then
what we
what we care about in the end is a
lookup Matrix
in this local Matrix each row represents
a word represented what representation
for individual words in the text
during the influence if we want to
generate a representation for a word we
simply import the one how to encoding of
that word and then we will multiply it
with this local Matrix in the end we get
what we want as a dance representations
and uh
although static embeddings Works quite
well but it does not take into
consideration about the context so in
some situations we will have examples
like this
one word may have different meanings in
different contexts
and if we want to have different
representations for
the word in different contexts we have
to consider using a dynamic embeddings a
dynamic embeddance usually uses a
bi-directional structure while training
and then during reference during
inference
the way it works is by not putting the
put in the word itself but put in the
whole sentence in this way the model can
capture the context information
now so far we have talked about the most
important Concept in LP I think it's
time to have a look what kind of chat
balls are there
so I have this classification based on
this implemented implementation of
chatbot
and the most simple chatbot has a
quite simple structure and it is purely
rule-based this type of chatbot usually
has a lot a list of questions and a list
of answers and we match on questions and
answers using keywords
group based chatbot is suitable for
customer service and use cases where we
have a limited number of questions
but if we want to now add more
functionalities to the chatbot it is not
so optimal
but luckily we have another solution for
that so which can help us reduce the
complexity when we Define the rules
so that is our intent-based chatbot
so I intent-based chatbot first
classifies questions into intents and we
only need to Define questions and
answers based on the intents but not for
each of these questions
and our immobility chatbot that I
developed is also our intent based
chatbot
so now finally I would like to explain
how I implemented our immobility chatbot
using waza framework
here is a real example that I took from
a conversation so we know that in a
conversation we have a lot of terms it
can be from the user and it can also
from the chatbot and for each of the
you also import we will classify our
intent for it
and in some cases we also care about the
small pieces of information that are
contained in the user import and so we
extracts the entities from it in our
case
for example in the intent kpi query we
have to extract three different
informations the kpi place and time
and
if we want to then use this informations
later in our conversations we need to
use a slot to store them
from the chatbot side
every response is associated with an
actions an action is where our business
logic goes it can execute events like as
simple as generating a
response or it can also make an API call
querying the database or setting a slot
value
and afterwards we have to also Define
stories for our chatbots as well as
rules if necessary a story is is a bunch
of intents and actions in order
this is a kind of abstraction where our
conversation should look like and
[Music]
rules is a special form of stories but
it is stricter which means that the
chatbot would always follow the rules
first and then the stories
so after we defined all the necessary
elements we have to think about how we
want to train the chatbot Raza provides
an AIU pipeline so it is straightforward
to see that so when a text comes in we
should first use a tokenizer to tokenize
it into tokens
then we use the futurizers to get the
embeddings from it
in the end and the two main tasks
for the chatbot is to classify the
intents and extracts entities
and for each of the components in this
pipeline there are different options for
which we can choose which model we want
to use
and also this pipeline is a highly
customized
um
for example in in our case we want to
also extract the name of the place
which is sometimes contain containing a
warm lot so I have to develop a
account on my own component for it so
which is here the rapid Force anti
extractors for place
but in general this pipeline can be
adjusted according to our needs
also we have to train the model to um
to change the chatbot to follow and ask
policies which tells it to um
choose on which Step it should take next
there are different types of policies
for example the rule policies which has
the highest priorities so the chatbot
would always follow the rules if we
Define one and the memorization policies
tells the chatbot to follow the stories
so
but there are also hyper parameters when
we can tune for example to let the model
to be more generalized
also if both of these policies do not
work we can consider using a Ted policy
which is machine learning based and
it will predict the next action based on
all the information from the
conversation so far like the user input
the slot value and so on
now let's have a quick look at how our
immobility chatbot looks like our
chatbot is very user friendly so at
beginning the chatbot will always Grace
the users and it will provide some in
menu whereas the chat and the user can
choose which service they want to use
if they choose kpi query then the
chatbot will provide a list of kpis so
which the user can query and as well as
some examples how the users can ask
their own queries
and then the user comes up with their
own query and the chatbot will
get the information from the input and
then query the database
in the end gives back to response
also some users are extremely interested
in knowing
how many charging points are located
along a certain place so we also have
developed this nearby Social Service
where it's based on an overpass API and
so the Usos only needs to give the
address of the search center as well as
search areas radius then the chatbot
will display the address in text as well
as gives back a map which displays how
where this charging points are located
of course our chatbot is also capable of
answering immobility related questions
and it is achieved by using a sentence
Transformer where the chatbot has a
knowledge base and
whenever the user asks questions it was
searched the knowledge base and gets
back the answer which has the highest
priority and probability
so with this approach we have built a
chatbot which is successfully running
and answering questions however we also
discovered some limitations of our
approach and I want to start with
intents here so a main task for an
intent based chatbot is to detect the
right intent and that can be challenging
so here you see an example conversation
of failure the user starts with choosing
the service immobility FAQ hence the
chatbot asks them what do you want to
know more about immobility so far so
good the user continues with with asking
which country has the most electric
vehicles which is a classic FAQ in
principle however the structure of this
sentence looks similar than sentences we
have in our training sample classified
with the intent kpi query which leads to
a wrong intent classification enhanced
to a wrong answer and the conversation
fails this problem might be mitigated by
a larger training sample however imagine
all the questions users could ask this
might also be a challenge
another thing with intense is that you
lose contextual information so in this
conversation here the user asks two
times about the number of charging
points in Berlin at two different dates
which is easy to answer but the chatbot
fails then afterwards when it get asked
to compare the two results because it
does not know about the context of the
last question
so these were two examples where we have
challenges with intents but I want to
name two more things we face
the first one is about the training data
so if you have a domain specific chat
bot like our immobility bot you also
need domain-specific training data and
depending on the domain this might not
be available in a large number and hence
can lead to some effort in collecting it
second we predefine the answers of the
chatbot and we also restrict the user in
the way they can ask questions this
helps the chatbot to better understand
the user and to react correctly but at
the same time it also leads to kind of a
robotic impression for the user
but there are also other ways how
chatbots can be built and I think it's
time in the end to have a quick look at
large language models and how they could
maybe help us also with our issues here
yes nowadays it's just not feeling so
right if we don't talk about activity
and large language model but it indeed
give us also some Inspirations how we
can improve our chatbots so let's start
with the definitions of large ranked
model
so a large language model is a large
neural network with usually billions of
parameters trained on large quantities
of unliable text
and let's take part as an example and
this also applies to many more other
large language models usually the
training takes place in two steps first
is the pre-training step where the model
is asked to
do two tasks which will help help it in
getting more um
meaningful representations of the text
then after we get this meaningful
representation so we can use it and to
fine tune on Downstream tasks such as
test text classification
and so how exactly can large language
model help to overcome some of our
challenges we discovered for our chatbot
the first thing that that we could do is
to use a large ranking model to generate
a data set for us
now I during the implementation of
immobility chatbot I actually generated
the data set manually
which is not really the type of work I
would like to do but I had to but
luckily we now have the creativity to
help us so the way it works is like you
create create a prompt and you basically
tell the chbt okay so imagine you are a
user who is now exploring this data set
and we also provide example questions
how many turning points did Berlin have
for example and then we asked to
attribute to generate three different
but similar questions and
if we want to add conditions we can also
write it in the prompt
in this way we get back three answers
from chbt
where the grammar is correct and it also
sounds very natural so
in this way we can generate a data set
in a short time
and we can also use large ranking model
to reduce the robotic impressions
and there are three different approaches
at least I can think of so for the first
approach
now we have the predefined response
template so the chatbot was always
trying to answer the questions using the
same structure of the response but once
we have threat GPT we can ask it to
refreeze the predefined template
and for the second approach we get rid
of this predefined template and we just
gave three GPT the data that we get back
from the database and we give it also
the user questions
and we asked Church PT to generate a
response on its own
and the third approach is a bit more
advanced where the creativity has also
too generally to SQL query and query the
database also get the data back and
generate the response so from the top
two button the control is less but we
have more Automation in our process
I also prayed around myself with the
first approaches and here are the
results
so for the first approach I simply asked
GPD to always rephrase on the text that
we give it
so
now if every time the user asks a
similar questions we have different
variations of answers from the chatbots
in this way okay so the user won't feel
like it's kind of robotic
and I also tested the second approach
where
the data that we give to LGBT is
basically the questions from the user as
well as the information which is the raw
data that we get back from the
database so it is not pre-processed and
we can see all the blankets along the
numbers
but surprisingly chpd can give us the
correct can extract the numbers from it
and also give us the correct response
and here it took me actually more time
to create a prompt because we know that
church PPT was trained Based on data
that was until September 2021
so if I also asked a question like how
many fast charging points did buying
have in December 2022 then charity would
say okay with I don't have the data um
from December 2022 so we we have to
explicitly tell the chatbot the
information that is given to you always
corresponds to the time the question
asks also we have to tell the chatbots
please don't mention word informational
data in your reply because otherwise the
chatbots would all just say based on the
information that I get I can say buying
had
1715 fast charging points so we have to
always tweak The Prompt a little bit to
get the correct answers
but in general I would say the first
approaches uh
both possible to do and also has its
potentials also even with the third
approach I did not try it myself but I
I could imagine that it is also possible
to do it so for example using
the recently
um
very popular Library like launching so
it has this um it can has its ability to
generate a circle queries actually
but we have one thing we have to keep in
mind is that large ranking model is not
a fixed for all and it also has its own
drawbacks um
because
um the more we trust on it the more
control we are giving away and we
sometimes also want to ensure that the
quality of the response is always good
so we would need some kind of evaluation
after we're getting
the response from the large Ranger model
and also in the real cases many
companies they cannot train their own
natural language models so they are
always dependent on a third-party
supplier
also we have to think about
the data privacy problems the model is
uh
is up and just provided as an API and it
is not open sourced so we don't have the
chance to
adjust models for our needs
okay so we're at the end of our talk so
let me quickly sum up what you've heard
about in the last 25 minutes
um
there is a variety of ways how chatbots
can be built one example we have shown
is to classify user questions in intents
using Raza and large language models
open the way for truly intelligent chat
Bots thanks
[Applause]
thank you nice presentation about the
underhoods the of the chatbot is there
some questions there's note on slido
is there someone out of the question we
have some time to answer
yes I will rephrase after you say it for
the people online
so have you experimented a non-closed
source large language model
um
have you experimented open source model
like shark GPT but open source versions
and not judge but not really I mean so
far I only played around with this um
GPT 3.5 API
okay yeah but I guess like the open
sourced models so we'll have
was performance probably and then it's
um non-open Source model
okay
another one yeah
so how was the acceptance about the
chatbot from the end user okay
okay so do they prefer the chatbot
instead of a map with the information
that uh self-service
yeah this is something we still have to
do because so far developed a chatbot
and it's a prototype and we will have to
do the user test later on and this
chatbot was developed when I was writing
my master thesis and it changed a little
bit on the functionalities at that time
what we get from the user is like the
responses are more kind of robotic so we
try to fix all these issues later
yes
um sorry you
Okay so
so the question is about integrating
chart GPT into the the chatbot and
restricting the information uh to what
we want for the immobility
was it for a smaller functionality for
example when we just gave it the
question and we give it the data and we
ask it to generate a response just based
on these two informations so
you know this was I I don't think there
will be like some
hallucination or kind of
fancy and stuff that's uh it has not
been told but it still come up with
itself
okay thank you we have we are learning
shots of time if your question is really
important you can go but otherwise I
will
uh so can we find the chatbot online uh
not yet but uh I'm sure we will put it
online please follow us
cool thank you a round of applause for
our presenters